hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy where we talk to influential
people in the education space about
learning and teaching
today we are pleased to welcome dr
barbara oakley who is uh celebrating the
launch of her new book uncommon sense
teaching and we will talk more about
that coming up before we get started i
wanted to remind you that khan academy
is a non-profit and we are able to do
our work of providing a free world-class
education to anyone anywhere thanks to
donations from folks like you so if you
are in a place where you are able to do
that you can find a link right at the
top of our website to make any kind of
donation that helps us keep continuing
this work thank you very much
in addition over the uh covet 19
pandemic we have had some
sponsors who have really helped us to
continue that learning and keep working
on making sure we are able to provide
that education so we want to in
particular thank bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors thank you
next if you are
looking for more of these kinds of
conversations you can find them via
podcasts our homeroom with sal the
podcast uh features audio versions of
many of these chats we have had so do
check that out wherever you get your
podcasts from
and as i said in the lead-in we are
excited today to be joined by dr barbara
oakley whose book uncommon sense
teaching practical insights in brain
science to help students learn is out
today we're going to be talking a lot
about how research about the brain helps
inform us about the things we should do
in our classrooms to help more students
learn more so welcome it's so nice to
have you
oh it's good to be here kristin
great
so to get things started i often like to
talk to people about how they got to be
experts in learning i know lots of
people take
different varied paths to get here what
was yours
oh um
i guess a bit different than some um my
father was a veterinarian and so i grew
up thinking oh i love animals i want to
be a veterinarian just like him except
that i couldn't do math at all uh
so i finally realized that have to give
up on my childhood dream
probably helped that i
i did a lot of cleaning of cages uh when
i was a kid and that could really change
your mind about some aspects of
veterinary science
but uh instead i became a professor of
engineering so go figure um i did a lot
of did you learn how to do math
i did learn how to do that
and actually i i didn't change
in my um
ability to do math until i was
26 years old
and i was getting out of the army and i
suddenly realized that all my friends
who
had a really good technical background
just had more doors open for them
professionally
and
i mean i would never trade the fact that
i i
really pursued my dream of learning a
language well although my russian is now
very very rusty unless i have a little
bit of wine or something like that but
we won't go there uh it comes right back
at that point but i i just
uh i i realized that
it would be a good idea for me to try to
broaden my passions instead of follow my
passions
and that maybe i really could start
learning in math and science
and
at that time they didn't have khan
academy available it was
so much easier for me
so instead i had to go to the university
start with remedial high school algebra
and slowly begin climbing my way upwards
but
the thing is if you just are slow and
steady and start at the lowest level
where you actually feel comfortable
and begin gradually practicing day after
day after week after even years
you can achieve far more than you ever i
mean
my high school algebra teacher would
have been like
you've got to be kidding me you know
that her
a professor of engineering you're you're
joking uh i'm actually a distinguished
professor of engineering
i'm a fellow in some engineering
societies and i publish in very good
journals and i mean i'm the real deal
i'm not a fake engineering professor but
uh as i the higher i got the more i fell
in love with math although i do have to
say that i i
am a very
mischievous professor because sometimes
i will go and look at some of saul's
tutorials
i will put them together and then i will
go and present them uh you know with a
courtesy thank you to solve but he just
presents things so beautifully that
sometimes even i was learning things uh
at advanced levels because he can help
you actually just
understand
some of those fundamental and actually
quite simple concepts at least simple
once he gets done explaining things
so i think that we really have not as
educators
acknowledged the value
of great teaching and great explanations
in helping students to move forward and
be successful at difficult areas like
science technology engineering and math
that totally makes sense so how did you
take being that professor of engineering
who i'm sure was publishing about
engineering and start moving into
thinking about how to help more people
learn and how
in thinking about brain science and how
to bring that into our understanding of
learning how did you make that
connection or shift
well because my first degree was in
slavic languages and literature
i have always had a broader set of
interests so it's not
it's not like
you have to be in one
discipline or silo in your life i've
been lucky enough to realize that
sometimes it's okay to be in the
humanities silo sometimes in the social
sciences
silo and sometimes in the more uh hard
science silo
and
so i've always liked writing as well as
doing math and engineering and i kept
that up even when i was um
doing my dissertation and even as i had
my early years as a professor of
engineering of course i kept it secret
that i was still writing on the side
because
other engineers
especially in academia
were not necessarily on board with the
idea of being broader than just
engineering
but
because i like to write i was always
looking at questions that interested me
and that led me to a lot of research
into what is going on in cognitive
psychology
and a good thing about looking at a
discipline when you're trained in a
completely different discipline is you
can more easily see holes and gaps in
that discipline so i saw a lot of great
research in cognitive psychology and a
lot of glaring
holes and
assumptions that really couldn't be made
because there was no solid sound
scientific foundation
and i i also worked
and
learned as much as i could about
neuroscience and uh and even genetics so
what do the hard sciences tell us about
how our brain is working
so then one day one of my students
asked the question
how did he found out about my terrible
past as a math flunky and he said how
did you change your brain
to be successful in math and science
and so i i wrote them a little email and
then i thought i like to write books why
don't i write a book about this i can
research it even more
and
that led to
me beginning to work in the discipline
of education and what i found is that a
lot of um
educators
um that there's sort of a disconnection
it's like
i know how to teach
um
secondary
mathematics
and i'm really good at it and that's
what i do but they don't really look at
the connection of
people going out into the working world
with that secondary mathematics
education and whether it actually fits
out there whether it actually builds a
good bridge for learning in science
engineering technology and technology
and mathematics
and so i um
i found that
there's i think an important need
for people like me who help
uh educators and help students and
teachers
to see
more concretely
that
the the complex interconnection between
education neuroscience
cognitive psychology
what's going on in the practical world
and tie that together uh in a way that
people can clearly and easily see what's
going on and that's that's sort of how
my work has emerged i think people just
liked it so much it was very encouraging
for me and that kind of kept me going
that's great and so your your new book
is uncommon sense teaching so tell me
about that title why is it uncommon
sense
oh okay so
first i thought
a lot of these ideas are just common
sense so
my colleague and co-author beth rogowsky
is a k-12 uh
she's a
a teacher
of teachers who teach to k-12
and she but she has a lot of experience
herself in k-12 classrooms and so you
know i had my bright idea i was like
beth we should call her book common
sense teaching
and beth about blew a gasket
because she said
a lot of these ideas
you may think they're common sense but
people are really not aware of them
it's not what
sometimes it's simply not what is taught
in schools of pedagogy even though it is
very well grounded with profoundly
effective
uh
research from neuroscience about how we
think and learn
so i i went away and stood for a while
you know because it's like here my great
idea was all shot down and
uh but beth was quite right about that
and uh and then finally one day it just
popped into my head well what about
uncommon sense teaching
and uh and beth wrote me back and she
was like well i didn't like the title
but i asked a bunch of friends and they
really liked it so now i think i like it
too so
that's how the title came about
can you can you give us an example of
something that
seems like common sense but maybe is not
that commonly used
well
so oh there's so many um
so you will often hear from people who
will say
you know you don't need to learn that
because you can always look it up
and
the reality is
let's say
ah french
i love the sound of french i love french
could i speak french if i just always
went and looked it up on google
translate
i mean i wouldn't have the neural
structure i would have
absolutely
no comprehension really of french if i
just always went and looked it up
so people might think well
okay i'll grant you that for language
but it's it's like this for
almost everything else well actually it
isn't
you
do not become an expert at anything
unless you have those key ideas embedded
in links between neurons of long-term
memory
and that can only happen
through not only explanations
but through your own active practice
with the material
even something as seemingly simple as
well
i want you to compare and contrast the
french and the russian and the american
revolutions
well
you could you could just think about it
as i can always go look it up
but you if you had to go and look up
when did each of those occur when did
they what were the key aspects who were
the key players
all of these things if you had to go
look that up because you didn't bother
to put anything in your long-term memory
you don't really understand
any of those fundamental concepts and
we've actually seen this play out with
things like
students who confuse
the civil war
with civil rights and they think that
abraham lincoln may be knew
martin luther king because they
didn't have to memorize any dates that
are affiliated with anything
so
building
really advanced higher level
um
you know bloom's taxonomy understanding
of information
arises
in a very important way from our
putting of
basic fundamental facts into our
long-term memory
so i mean that's that's just one example
i could probably yeah yeah
so no that's great um so that's the the
declarative knowledge side of things in
the book you also talk about procedural
skills and what what kinds of things are
we learning from
brain science about
being able to learn procedural skills
so the brain has
almost like two major
super highways that it uses to deposit
information in your long-term memory
the first superhighway is the
declarative highway or pathway and that
goes through the hippocampus
and we've long known that if you
like happen to be missing your
hippocampus oh you know i put it around
here someplace
if you're missing it
you can't really depositive things
you've learned declaratively into your
long-term memory so a very famous
patient henry mullison
had both of his hippocampi removed and
if you were introduced to him
he would greet you and he'd be a lovely
man and you walk out of the room
and then you wait a minute or two you
walk back in and he would not remember
you and you'd have to be reintroduced
but let's say that you walked in and met
henry
and you were a mischievous sort
and you had in your hand a pin
i'm not suggesting to do this in real
life but actually psychologists have
done this with patients who are similar
to henry
and you you shook henry's hand
what would happen is if you walked out
and you walked back in
and you introduced yourself again henry
would not know who you were and he'd be
very glad to meet you and if you reached
out with your hand to shake hands with
him
he would not shake your hand
he had learned and he had remembered
something and that was because
he was able to remember about the pin
prick through his procedural system of
the basal ganglia
that that deposit sets of links in
long-term memory and that's why henry
could
not remember you or your face but kind
of remember that you are associated with
a handshake that is a big owie
and so this procedural kind of learning
is actually like half of what we learn
anything that we have to know really
well so that we don't really want to
have to think about it like our native
language for example
we
learn that procedurally
and that means that we can speak
extemporaneously without having to think
about what we were
were actually saying
and this is why
uh for example let's say that you have a
simultaneous translator who or or a
a translator who has
learned another language but it's not
their native language
it can actually be exhausting
to translate because you're often using
that declarative system to bring in
um
you know to think about things
whereas if you can just think about it
using your procedural system speaking in
your native language it's not exhausting
at all because it's habitual and you've
got those sets of links um
in procedural memory so what this means
is for learners it is
invaluable to develop not only
declarative
kind of factually related sets of links
in long-term memory oh the date is this
date
but also procedural sets of links
so it this relates more to
um
like complex patterns
um how do you work math problems like
this as opposed to like another as
opposed to like a third type
how do you um how do you work all of
these kinds of problems
you only develop
the intuition or seeming intuition
of how to do these kinds of problems
by practicing with lots of different
types getting lots of feedback about
whether what you've done to try to solve
that problem is correct
and then trying again and interleaving
different
closely related examples so that you can
see
for example what is
the geometric distribution
versus what is the negative binomial
distribution versus what is the binomial
distribution and you you can actually
see when you use one when you use
another and how to do these things
oftentimes in classes what you actually
learn is
okay
here's an example of binomial
distribution
and and you do like a dozen problems of
it and you think you know it really well
but then you're faced with a new problem
that's negative binomial and
you're like now wait a minute
what's going on here uh
you if you haven't practiced to train
the difference between these things uh
then you
um
you don't know what those differences
are and this is where a lot of practice
with your procedural learning system
uh can be so valuable and i have to ask
you
what what does khan academy do
to help
learners with their procedural learning
well
what you were just describing
hopefully those out uh listening have
heard a lot of things that sound like
khan academy
because we are absolutely based in uh
while some folks know us as videos
the exercises that are
we woven in and linked to those videos
are key uh to the learning experience at
khan academy and so as
we see those exercises as the active
learning that practice component you
were talking about where students can
start doing a number of problems that
are kind of similar to each other and
then
somewhat different
and then
when they get to
uh you know having done a few of those
in a row we actually give them
problems that have a couple of different
related skills and they have to figure
out which one to use which one to apply
um as as kind of the extra added layer
of difficulty but essentially that is a
key thing that we at khan academy see is
one of our main purposes as a
supplemental tool for students in
classrooms and working on their own to
be able to provide that extra practice
so those those links you were talking
about those neural connections are
forming and getting stronger
well you you really could not be more in
line with what brain science is
revealing about how we should learn
it does make me laugh because see what
notice how you framed what you're doing
it's like closely related concepts that
you're interleaving
sometimes
um teachers can
unwittingly get the idea that uh
interleaving means just having something
and then having something different
but it isn't the the key to interleaving
is it has to have
you want students to know
notice the difference between
closely related patterns
so like if you're teaching
punctuation and you interleave that with
things like
uh questions about metaphors um
you know that that's not interleaving
they're too far apart but if you talk
about what's a metaphor as opposed to a
simile
as opposed to an analogy now you're
talking interleaving
so that's that's the real
that's when you really start building
that um procedural intuition is with the
closely related interleaved concepts
great
so as usual time is flying i want to get
to a couple questions that are coming in
from the folks that are watching i know
um so it's funny you just talked about
similes and metaphors
this is kind of a different question but
it relates to it so susanna garcia
dominguez from youtube asks
hello dr oakley could you please share
about the use of metaphors and analogies
to help people learn
how can we effectively use them
oh
you know jiminy
can i share something that would
show this idea very very clearly if i
could come on barb
tell me you can or is it possible if it
isn't possible i don't think i don't
think we can do a screen share uh oh but
if you want to if you want to point
someone to somewhere where they could
look that would be or handle
so here's the thing so you have you
create this set of of interlinked
neurons
and you can just think of it like you've
got this nice little golden necklace
with nice links between them
so let's say you know what
the flow of water is
that actually in your own mind that is a
set of
uh
of linked neurons and it's like a
complex set so you've got this net of
neurons and that net
is is your understanding that you've
developed ever since you were a little
kid
watching water flow
now let's say that you're trying to
explain how electrical current flows so
that's like
molecules well it's electrons
moving the other way then you actually
think of electron but anyway so it's the
motion of particles
which is
somewhat analogous to the flow of water
because you already have that set of
links
for understanding how water flows
you can much more easily understand the
flow of electrical current
because it's got a lot of the same those
key ideas of movement
of
of particles
so
it turns out that
that
using metaphors or using analogies
uh a similarity a likeness between
something you know
and something you wish to convey
is an incredibly powerful tool in
in education and in learning
and it's in part related to a
a theory called neural reuse theory
which means if we've already built
our understanding of something we can
reuse some of those same neurons
you know to help us better and more
easily understand new ideas and new
concepts
so
sometimes
people will say
yes but the analogy breaks down after a
while the metaphor breaks down if you
get to a quantum level uh in how
electrical current flows
it's not at all like how water flows and
that's true
but whenever a metaphor breaks down you
just get a new metaphor and indeed uh
emmanuel durman of who's a great
physicist uh turned uh financial analyst
said that all mathematical equations
are simply metaphors
so um
and i think there's a great deal of
truth to that
so anyway i'm a keen proponent of
metaphors and especially visual
metaphors because they can help students
learn so much more quickly
great thank you
uh let's
i think we have time for one more
and from akshat dubi on youtube i've
been struggling with making habits for a
long time uh
what are some tips to help me create a
new habit
i just do it over and over and over and
over and over again
i know that sounds silly
but
um
let me just give you an example let's
say that you are
um
driving home you're driving home you've
done it a hundred times before
and you think of something else you know
that that day that you is really
important like you should have put
something into a um
a report and you forgot to do it well 45
minutes later you arrive at home and you
can't even remember how you got home
well how'd you get home then i mean how
did you learn to do that well
you have driven home so many times that
actually your procedural system has
learned it and you can drive home
without even thinking about it as a
consequence unless somebody does
something bizarre in a car right ahead
of you or something
but
so what this means is in our daily lives
for example my
uh
let's see
i wanted our daughters
our two daughters to have all career
doors open for them
so
for many many children mathematics is
not fun
and when you try to make it fun it may
become fun but it may not be necessarily
a good learning experience
so i just made a habit of 20 minutes
every day um
my my girls our girls did some extra
math practice
we used kumon math i think if khan
academy had been around at that time we
would have been using khan academy but
they did this extra practice
interleaving closely related concepts
and they didn't want to do it most of
the time it was sometimes pushing and so
forth but it was the habit that i
developed in them you just do this for
20 minutes a day that's who you are
and
by golly our older daughter who's
let's say not a natural talent um
with mathematics
finished her medical residency at
stanford
you know and it's this early training
that just sort of a little bit of extra
practice 20 minutes a day
that habit
actually helped her so she's got she did
have all career doors open for even if
you might have said early on
this kid's uh you know she's not gonna
go anywhere with math our younger
daughter was more natural at math she
simply hated it so um
so but she had to do it anyway and uh
she went off and she became an artist
and now she's back at school getting her
master's degree in statistics so
uh it did keep those doors open for so
for me duolingo i use duolingo and i
practice my
you know my spanish or my russian each
day and it helps a lot
yeah
great so i think that's a a good theme
to
uh close on that keep practicing it
builds those pathways it builds those
skills
thank you for joining us today uh again
uh the the new book publication day
today congratulations uncommon sense
teaching uh for those of you that are
looking for uh for some new guidance in
the classroom i highly recommend it
definitely pick it up and get some both
the the suggestions and the why that
these are the suggestions to to try in
your classroom so thanks so much for
being with us today thanks to all of you
in the audience and we'll see you next
time
oh and our daughter actually got into
statistics because she took a lot of
khan academy uh courses watched so many
videos so i should add that in so that's
actually a true story she said so i
got me through calculus so thank you
thank you for for that good good
endorsement of what we're doing we'd
love to hear stories from people who
have used our materials thank you
thank you
you